[Music]
sure adele's new single easy on me is
the official heartbreak anthem of 2021
but in a new interview with rolling
stone the 33 year old singer reveals
that her highly anticipated upcoming
album 30 was just inches away from never
seeing the light of day
[Music]
30 is set to drop on november 19th and
features songs inspired by her 2019
divorce from her ex-husband simon kaneki
what's my next album to be based on um
divorce babe divorce the album's release
was delayed for more than a year due to
the pandemic and adele says if it had
been postponed any longer she quote
would never put it out quote i know i
would have changed my mind and been like
it's moved on let's start the next album
and i couldn't do that to this album i
feel like it deserves to come out
[Music]
the grammy winner also opened up about
the end of her marriage from simon they
share a nine-year-old son quote it made
me really sad then having so many people
that i don't know know that i didn't
make that work it
devastated me i was embarrassed no one
made me feel embarrassed but you feel
like you didn't do a good job adele
previously opened up about her marriage
in october during an interview with
vogue explaining quote it just wasn't
right for me anymore i didn't want to
end up like a lot of other people i knew
it wasn't miserable miserable but i
would have been miserable had i not put
myself first and adele told the mag that
she hoped the new album would someday
answer her son's questions about his
parents split i changed
quote i just felt like i wanted to
explain to him through this record when
he's in his 20s or 30s who i am and why
i voluntarily chose to dismantle his
entire life in the pursuit of my own
happiness it made him really unhappy
sometimes and that's a real wound for me
that i don't know if i'll ever be able
to heal it's an amazing thing to show my
son he knows i'm a powerful force he
feels it just at home
let alone you know when he comes to work
with me of course now adele is dating
sports agent rich paul i feel very lucky
the easy on me singer confirmed the two
are a thing in that same interview with
the vogue gushing that they are quote
very happy and it seems like she's
finally met her prince after briefly
kissing the frogs of hollywood in her
sit down with rolling stone she says
dating in la quote lasted five minutes
you know since dating when you're famous
isn't all that easy quote you can't set
me up on a blind date i'm like how's
that going to work there'll be paparazzi
outside it ain't happening
you